[Music]
said
my daughter for a
final
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
there's someone moving in across the
street maybe they'll have a girl your
age
be nice for you to have a friend
[Laughter]
they became to everyone who knew them
simply tully and kate
and for more than 30 years that
friendship was the bulkhead of their
lives
[Music]
things are hard over at her house in
ways that
you might not understand
i'm gonna be there for you no matter
what
when we grow up we're gonna live
together and we're gonna be famous
journalists
i am a goddamn legend in the making
that's right you are
[Music]
you don't get it you don't know what
it's like to fail and you succeeded
everything you tried
it's like this is your life and i'm just
along for the ride you are so much
braver than me
your family that is the real
accomplishment i will never have that i
was too scared to even try
i need you and my soul mate you [ __ ]
if i could how long have you been
wanting to
do the d with the man who signs your
paycheck
live from seattle this
is tully high wow
[Music]
you cross the line tully you don't even
know there is a line
[Music]
the music might have changed with the
decades
but the promises made on firefly lane
remained
best friends forever
say hello
who the hell are you neighborhood watch
maybe you should mind your own business
i've tried but it turns out i'm really
bad at it
what's up with you mom out of nowhere
you quit your job last month and won't
talk about it
you love traveling all over the world
being the big shot at your charity
it's complicated this new side gig of
yours is raising questions
the company must be pretty desperate if
they sent your skinny ass up here well
they figured you'd kill anybody else
they want you back robin you're the best
they had i don't work for them anymore
i'm using my powers for good
why do i have a feeling this is not a
social call i need your freaky ass super
powers
one two three hit it
this world is just looking for a reason
to put a young black girl on that side
of the fence
don't help them
when i can't sleep it's not because all
the things i've done
it's because of all the people i
couldn't say
do you really think she could help if
anyone can i'm super bad
it's mccall
how many people are out there desperate
with no way to turn
they have some way to turn
to me
no matter how hard i try to protect my
family it will always end in tragedy
i can no longer be the man i was black
lightning was trying to save the world
i'm just trying to save my family
you are a symbol of justice for a city
that badly needs it black lightning
new episodes monday february 8th free
next day only on the cw at
almost
you are a woman with a very public
reputation
for hunting monsters i can't have a
reputation i've only done it once
it's time you own that reputation
it's time to come out of hiding
starlings
take me home
to the place
where i belong so how long has it been
when's the last time you went back to
appalachia it's been years
a lot of old ghosts
this isn't buffalo territory anymore
starling we do evidence
not it's a full moon and i've got a
feeling so you keep quiet until i tell
you
and then you will say what i tell you dc
is living in fear i don't like this this
is deep in dark claries
[Music]
this is getting worse it always gets
worse
i know you have your own demons to carry
but you're the only one who can help
whose stories are worth telling who's
worth hearing
never let anyone decide that for you
[Music]
that was a lie i'll never be safe
[Music]
i like whatever this is hide that that's
what makes you you
you're engaged this is crazy fast
[Music]
tell me what you did with other women it
turns me on
[Applause]
i had this hallucination
i don't want to ruin this i want to be
connected to you forever
something around you is making you sick
tell me what's really going on
tell me what the hell is going on
who are you i don't know
a land that is cut through with locks
and mountains
that weave like some kind of tartan
and you you were gonna go there which is
called
scotland scotland
[Music]
we're going on the trip of a lifetime i
spent a lot of time here obviously
shooting outlander
what is portrayed in the show is
truthful in many ways
time travel this is truthful yeah i
wasn't necessarily thinking of the time
travel a bit
story of two men who know nothing
i don't know what to do i cannot believe
that this was your idea of a good time
this is a great example of amazing
scottish seafood
the soldiers would dance the swords
before they went into battle
the origination of highland games would
come from the clan
this land tells a story of its people
thank you for having us us back to sure
captain
would be great make it so make it so
seriously
have you been waiting all day to say
that yeah
that is impressive
[Music]
[Music]
kilts men in kill
kill several trip with samurai
the man is dead do you think the
defendant killed your husband mrs wells
i know she did i don't know what
happened last night
i don't remember anything
was this your first sea voyage yes mine
too you're probably bound for new
zealand
to dig it for gold same as me well yes
mr emery stains miss anna wetheron
women in this country are outnumbered a
dozen to one you're on your own
why do you ask i operate a fortune pilot
with my husband
crosby wells you're really here all
alone
you must have someone there was a kind
of magic between us
you see fate is what's meant to happen
if i can convince you that a path is
destined for you
that's the person you choose
but that's not a fate that's just you
the world's gone man what happened last
night miss weather
if i told you you wouldn't believe me i
didn't kill him
i remember things they're in my head
like they happened to me
whatever you know whomever you're
protecting now is the time to tell the
truth
you don't want me as your enemy i don't
want you as my friend
what you see is who you are
i know what kind of woman she is i'm not
a fool
[Music]
we hadn't met none of this would have
happened
[Music]
look i'm sure jesse is a good driver but
you already got a great one he's had a
bad year he didn't finish three races
right we're a team
you know just because he's behind the
wheel you cannot pin this on him okay
richmond
richmond was his fault but in his
defense he saw a cloud that looked like
abraham lincoln
i mean it was yeah
can i have everyone's attention please
well it's been a great ride but
catherine's moving back home and taking
over
guys meet your new boss you gotta be
kidding me
i have underwear older than her i don't
want to fire anyone but i'm gonna do
what i have to do
to win she can't fire us all we're a
family
jake is like a son to me chuck it's like
a brother money
mirrors i found a mint or a xanax either
way it can only help
no it's a pebble
think of this as war our best odds are
to stick together
oops i missed well no you just nailed
the fawn
how do you like your car set up jake
just hits the gas and tries to finish
first i'm guessing that's also how he is
with his ladies
yeah it is
when have i ever let you guys down what
about that time i got arrested in
jacksonville i'm not talking about
little stuff
okay
there's nothing stopping us from being a
top ten team by the end of the season
top 20. sounds funny jay can make top 20
right jake no now he's sleeping
we had a meeting at nine well no one
told me did you turn on your
notifications
yeah it's on now
got it
to understand me you gotta understand
where i came from
dwayne johnson for the 2032 u.s
presidential race
are the people ready they are not ready
but they need to see it
let me just take you back to when i was
10 years old living in hawaii
i was born into a wrestling family of
course your dad was wrestling superstar
the soul man rocky johnson to me he was
a superhero
hey romeo and juliet pay attention we've
got gladiators in the ring
i learned a lot of lessons very early on
in life
at the same time i was just a regular
little boy i'll have your finest tequila
no i'll have a vodka martini no
you have a full mustache and you're
bigger than a dab you look like an
undercover cop i'm 15.
[Music]
i'll put you over with the guys what by
telling them i was gonna be on a
wheaties box
[Applause]
surprise
[Music]
nothing is more important than family
you know when you grow up around
wrestlers sometimes you learn lessons in
very interesting ways
so fake anyways
what happened
i got big dreams for us my big dream is
you
i have had one hell of a life there's
still so much that i have to share with
the world
oh and i've got some pretty cool stories
about andre the giant
[Music]
who's there what was that doing she just
made what are you even doing up i
thought we had a break in what were you
gonna do give him the [ __ ] i was gonna
hit him in the face and then say
sax to be you that actually would have
been dope
[Music]
keenan man listen to your brother after
corey pass i can't move on
at all does keena need an extra set of
hands to help with the girls
sure that's why papa rick's here i got
to go to work can you do the dishes
oh god no
[Music]
good morning atlanta starting today
we're covering hard news
you want to be a serious news guy now
just remember the 3ds
deny deflect the blind
duane defrost now that's chicken yeah
you're right shut the hell up okay
oh uh i forgot my wallet in florida
yes hey mom's old church hats
that thing ruined a lot of people's view
of jesus
come here babies know him about that hug
life just
[Music]
let your daddy bake you something how
about a pie cake and i made one on the
show this morning did you make it or did
you just throw a bunch of ingredients in
a bowl and then pull out a pre-made
thing snitches get stitches
they really do
[Music]
we're concerned
the soviets might be trying to introduce
a new weapon
we let this go
it would set a dangerous precedent
welcome to nasa you are as of this
moment officially astronaut candidates
someday people will write the history of
this time
this is jamestown actual 10 seconds
they will say that during the coldest
depths of the cold war
america inspired the world
i give you pathfinder it's three times
as powerful as our current shuttles
i'm tired of talking about the good old
days
i don't miss it
with this weapon they could drop
munitions on any point on earth
the president wants you to put together
a new mission
i shouldn't go you don't think i noticed
the look in your eyes at every launch
[Applause]
[Music]
i have here the rules of engagement for
use of force on the moon
that's steps away from nuclear war
target lock
once we do this thing there's no going
back
[Music]
this program has the power to
change the world
you need to remind them of apollo 11.
we came in peace for all mankind ready
to fire
we need to live up to that
[Music]
[Music]
when we were dreaming about having a
family didn't look like this did it
lost jobs teens with severe anxiety
parents condition
[Music]
why'd you move the family here still
looking for the simple life
[Music]
as those days are gone clark long gone
you got the weight of the world on your
shoulders i really wish i could get
drunk sometimes
you're saying you're super mad
no we've seen superman before we've seen
him
am i a bad father we're gonna be all
right
no one ever dreams about the problems
but every life has done
even the extraordinary ones
[Music]
superman and lois two-hour premiere
event tuesday february 23rd
stream free next day only on the cw app
pete i got you a present ah gross
this is the new thing you're doing now
hate on mom come on
this isn't us we're like the gilmore
girls but with bigger boobs
my mom had me when she was my age you're
gonna like massachusetts perfect for a
fresh start
we move a lot so i'm always the new girl
who's sad that is jenny's mom
i know i'm such a psycho
jenny's thriving here she has friends
this adorable little boyfriend
monk rowan kiss like three times that's
it
seriously i blame toxic masculinity why
i
i don't know okay you're new right just
moved in across the street i met your
mom last night yeah well she can be very
friendly
she asked me for weed she wasn't that
friendly well she can also be kind of
happy sweet 16 jerk god my crush on
georgia grows every day
is that weird yes sorry we play this
game
twice my mom deals with her problems by
ignoring them
bundling them up and packing it away
the only man i've ever seen her love is
my dad and that never ends well
she promised that this time would be
different but everywhere has problems
we live in a man's world and it is
exhausting to exist in a world where you
matter less
i've met george miller and i do believe
her to be dangerous
i'm sick of the lies i want answers
you're past
everything i feel like i don't even know
who my mother is
[Music]
i've done things i'm not proud of but
i'd do them again i'd do anything to
protect my kids like no one ever
protected me
anything it's me and you against the
world kid remember that
[Music]
eb join the system
and let it destroy you
[Music]
we're fighting
how low can you go we expanded
it's time we grow past that lake
more product coming over the border
means more competition
let's roll turn it off i like them off
the board
they're bad for business i'm gonna kill
everyone to get in my way
there's things i can help you with and
things i can't i'm stopping a gang war
falls in the ladder if we go to war
we ain't gonna survive it you might know
where we live
we ain't running from nobody
here we go again give me some reason to
believe that we can make it out intact
who's protecting franklin and why
my fate's tied to your conflict to
nicaragua
how much longer you think the good old
usa stays involved
i have sacrificed everything for this
mission drugs
corruption at the highest levels you see
anything
you have something on me
head now
i want to see franklin saint in prison
don't do it fine you can't trust anyone
shelf life in my line of work's pretty
limited
snowfall premieres wednesday february
24th
on fx next day fx on hulu
you